hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A I'm Jason Bradley and I'm so glad
that you've decided to open God's word
with us today we are going to go to
God's word to find the answers to the
questions that you've submitted and if
you're sitting there and you're like
well I didn't send any questions in we
want to answer your questions in future
programs so please text your questions
to 618 228
3975 again that's 618 228
3975 or email your questions to Bible
QA 3abn.org
3: 18 it says but grow in the grace and
knowledge of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ to him be the glory both now and
forever amen if you don't already have a
pen and a piece of paper I'd like to
encourage you to grab one because our
panelists pastor rafy and Pastor densey
will be answering your questions rather
rapidly in four or five minutes and so
you'll want to write down these Bible
verses and in addition to that we want
to encourage you to go to God's word for
yourself and study this out they can
only say so much in four and five
minutes but we want you to do an indepth
study on some of the questions that are
presented today and uh hopefully that
will help to facilitate that growth in
your spiritual life so without further
Ado I'd like to introduce uh the
panelist today we have Pastor James rafy
welcome pastor raferty
hey Jason good to be here Pastor John
good to join you both as we uh peruse
some of these questions and look for
biblical answers amen amen Pastor densey
it's great to have you here as well it's
a blessing to be here and it's always uh
interesting looking at the questions and
relying on the Lord for answers H
because he has given us an abundant
amount of information in the scriptures
and uh he's also promised the Holy
Spirit and that's what we depend on on
the holy scriptures and the holy spirit
amen amen would you pray for us before
we go to God's word sure let's go to the
Lord in prayer Our loving Heavenly
Father we are grateful to you for your
kindness and mercy we thank you Lord for
this day of life and we thank you for
the opportunities that you provide for
your children every day and Lord as we
participate in this program we ask for
your Holy Spirit upon Pastor James
myself and uh uh brother Jason and for
your Holy Spirit to also guide the
understanding of your children that will
be listening to this program we thank
you for providing 3abn to reach the
world and we pray that in this day more
and more people will give their hearts
to Jesus we ask you for these things in
the holy and blessed name of Jesus amen
amen amen amen thank you Pastor rafy
will come to you with this first
question here uh I talk about others
sometimes I do not I do try not to say
anything bad about them and although
it's not one of the Ten Commandments I
believe God doesn't care for gossiping
is gossiping a
sin well yes we certainly agree with
your conclusion regarding this question
that as you stated God doesn't care for
gossiping now talking about others is
life at its finest or at its worst the
problem is not in talking we talk about
our family we talk about our friends we
talk talk about our fellow workers we
talk about our community and our
government our leaders we talk about God
so talking about others is not the issue
the issue is what we say are we being
truthful in our conversation does the
Bible talk about this does the Bible
talk about it in the Ten Commandments of
God well yes actually it does the bible
States in Exodus 20 and verse 16 Thou
shalt not bear false witness against Thy
Neighbor now what does that mean well
that covers fault speaking in any matter
every attempt every purpose to deceive
our neighbor is included in this an
intention to deceive constitutes
falsehood a glance of the eye a motion
of the hand an expression of the
countenance a falsehood can be told as
effectively as by words so every
intentional uh attempt to overstate
every hint or insinuation calculated to
convey something erroneous or
exaggerated in its expression even a
statement of facts that can be shared in
a manner as to mislead is falsehood and
it's a violation of this commandment so
this precept is actually forbidding uh
every effort that we put forth
intentionally and even unintentionally
to well to misrepresent our neighbor or
injure their reputation right by evil
surmising or slander or tail bear and
even we can even tell the truth or let's
say suppress the truth and that could
lead to an injury to others and that is
a violation of the ninth commandment so
it's not just what we say it's sometimes
what we don't say and you know the heart
is very deceitful when it comes to the
expression of words um the Bible
describes this as not gossip but tail
bearing or Whisperer in Romans chapter 1
ver 29 this is one of the sins the many
sins that Paul identifies among people
he says that they're filled with all
unrighteousness and with fornication
with wickedness and with covetousness
and maliciousness and they're full of
envy and murder and debate and deceit
and malignity and their Whisperers
Whisperers can you imagine Whisperers
being there on the same level as
murderers uh in Proverbs 18 and verse 8
the words of a tail Bearer are as wounds
and they go down to the very innermost
parts of the belly so the Bible
describes tail bears and Whisperers as
gossipers the Bible tells us also that
it's difficult for most of us to tame
the tongue uh James 3: 8-13 talk about
how the tongue is an unruly evil and we
bless God and then we curse men which
are made after the image of God and
these things shouldn't be happening so
there are times though when we may need
to speak the truth so it is important to
know the difference between
truth-telling and tail bearing right
sharing biblical truth is necessary for
our growth in God's grace the Bible
tells in second Timothy that the
scriptures are given for reproof and
correction and instruction righteousness
so gossiping or tail bearing is a sin
but truth telling is not and telling the
truth in love is a necessary part of our
Christian journey in Grace Grace so I
hope that this has been helpful in
addressing your question about uh
gossiping and I hope that the holy
spirit will lead you and guide you to
know what words to speak and what words
not to speak when you're talking about
others wow that was a great answer you
just peeled back so many layers within
four three yeah four minutes great great
answer uh Pastor deny I was confronted
by a friend who said that the Seventh
Day Adventist Church teaches that there
are some unfallen worlds in the universe
what supporting scripture can I give to
help my friend understand this subject
clearly uh that's a very good question
and there are hints in the Bible about
other worlds it doesn't clearly SP uh
spell out let's say uh there are X
amounts of other worlds but let's take a
look at some thoughts first let's take a
look at some ideas um have you ever
considered how many kinds of plants
there are in the world there about 300
91,000 kinds of plants wow of which
there are over 2,000s that are fruits
are you hungry there are over 2,000
kinds of fruits that you can eat uh and
so think about these things how about
animals this uh there's about 7.7 is
estimated 7.7 million kind of species of
animals so this helps me to understand
that God is a a a creative God a God
that has imagination a God that has
variety and so to think that the Earth
is the only planet that has living
intelligent beings that's limiting God
that's putting God in a box and so I
would think uh with uh assurance that
God created all worlds uh are they
within our reach not at this time so the
idea that also I would like to just put
in here right now the idea of aliens
coming from other worlds to destroy the
Earth or take over the Earth that's sin
has not entered into those worlds so the
I don't be afraid of aliens coming to to
um uh people are afraid that they're
going to come inside people and start uh
uh controlling people that's science
fiction that's science fiction and so
God is taking care of this world there
are people that are worried about uh
some something colliding with the Earth
and destroying the Earth that again is a
fear here God is taking that God is in
control God is protecting this Earth
from those type of things um let's go
ahead and look at some scriptures that
give us some idea that there is uh other
worlds Hebrews chapter 1 is where I
began Hebrews chapter one beginning in
verse one God who at various times and
in various ways spoke in time past to
the fathers by the prophets has in these
last days spoken to us by his son whom
he has appointed heir of all things
through whom also so he made the worlds
so it it gives us this this uh word
worlds here and and some translation
will say the universe so God has made
other worlds uh let's go to Psalms 103
and I'll begin in verse 20 go to verse
22 bless the Lord you his angels who
excel in strength who do his word
hearing the voice of his word bless the
Lord all you his hosts well who are
these mhm and so it continues you
Ministers of his who do his pleasure
bless the Lord all his Works who can
praise the
Lord and it says in all places of his
Dominion There Are Places of God's
Dominion Beyond this Earth uh bless the
Lord oh my soul so this is another
scripture that helps us to see uh that
there are some hints in the Bible about
other worlds uh the other one that I can
give you is revelation 12: 10-12 uh
here's a hint as well and it says
beginning in verse 10 then I heard a
loud voice saying in heaven now
salvation and strength and the kingdom
of our God and the power of His Christ
have come for the accuser of our
Brethren who accused them before our God
day and night has been cast down and
they overcame him overcame him by the
blood of the lamb and by the word of
their testimony and they did not love
their lives to the death therefore
notice Rejoice oh Heavens wait a minute
what are we saying here Rejoice all
heavens and now notice and you who dwell
in them so uh Rejoice all those other
planets all those inhabitants of other
planets this is what I can understand
from this Rejoice of heavens and you who
dwell in them woe to the inhabitants of
the earth and the Sea for the devil has
come down to you having great wrath
because he knows that he has a short
time so the idea that God has only
created this Earth with life and with
intelligent beings is limiting God it's
putting God in a box God is a creative
God a Creator God that uh has created
other worlds and to some degree I could
I could even say that this world uh now
this is uh this world may be off limits
uh for us to go to other planets I mean
think about it uh they have been looking
through these telescopes hes and they
haven't found life near us so God has
placed Us in this position so that we do
not have contact with other beings at
this time is not necessary at this time
amen thank you but we were going to have
a chance to see all those other worlds
uh when after Jesus returns amen thank
you for that answer you know I think
about job when there was that meeting
that took place in in the Book of Job
you know that shows that there were
other worlds out there as well um Pastor
rafy the Bible seems to imply that we're
not supposed to do anything beyond
having a basic job when it comes to
money if I start a business or make
investments I may be laying up Treasures
on Earth or serving Mammon Proverbs
frequently addresses the evils of
poverty and how it will come if we don't
work hard the Bible also says that
wealth is a blessing from God some of
the most prominent Bible characters were
rich like job Abraham lot DAV David
Solomon and Joseph of ARA
ARA uh is it a sin to try to grow
financially through starting a business
or making Investments thank you for this
question about money and wealth it's a
great question very important one a very
practical one no it is not a sin to grow
financially in fact Jesus uh at times
really help people to understand uh this
truth
you know in Jesus time there was an
opposite View and that was that if you
were poor that was a sign you were being
a sinner now we're asking the question
if you're rich is that a sign that
you're treasure you know laying up
treasure on Earth and not really
spiritual but in Jesus day if you were
poor it was an indication that maybe God
wasn't blessing you so between these two
opposite ways of thinking uh that we're
not supposed to be rich or we're not
supposed to be poor there's a kind of a
Biblical perspective that's more Bal
balanced so let's take a look at some
key Bible verses that will bring us this
more balanced understanding first one we
want look at well I think most of them
are going to be right here in 1 Timothy
chapter 6 I want to look at verses 6-2
and then verses 17 to 19 1 Timothy
chapter 6 beginning with verse
6 but godliness with contentment is
great gain we brought nothing into this
world and it is certain that we can
carry nothing out and having food and
reignment let us there with be content
but they that will be rich fall into
temptation and a snare and into many
foolish and hurtful lusts which drown
men in destruction and predition For the
Love of Money is the root of all evil
which while some have coveted after they
have aired from the faith and Pierce
themselves through with many Sorrows but
thou oh man of God flee these things and
follow after righteousness godliness
Faith love patience meekness fight the
good fight of Faith lay hold on eternal
life where unto thou are also called and
H has professed a good profession before
many witnesses verse 17 charge them that
are rich in this world that they be not
highminded nor trust in uncertain riches
but in the Living God who gives us
richly all things to enjoy that they do
good that they be rich in Good Works
ready to distribute willing to
communicate laying up in store for
themselves a good foundation against the
time to come come that they may lay hold
on eternal life so I think these verses
these Bible verses uh Paul here speaking
to Young Timothy who he's mentoring are
very balanced we find that God does give
us wealth he does give us riches we've
see that all through the Bible but he
does it so that we're ready to
distribute to others notice these Bible
verses do not command those who are rich
to be poor oh if you're rich be poor God
wants to bless us he wants to bless his
people with wealth so that they can be a
Channel of blessing to others so God
cannot trust wealth to just everyone
because well the Love of Money can
become a root of evil and and money
often changes people right it changes
people's personalities it can bring out
the worst in Fallen human nature uh but
there are men and there are women
everywhere that God can trust with
wealth because they'll use it for good
we see this all through the Bible we see
some people who are tripped up by wealth
like Solomon eventually was we see
others like zakus who is very wealthy
and ended up coming to the Lord and aart
departing departing um parting his
wealth to poor people and helping people
who were in need and of course we see
Joseph arthea doing the same thing
giving his own grave his own tomb to
Jesus in his burial we see Nicodemus
also coming to the front and helping the
church then we see ananas and SA fire
who withheld some of their riches so
it's not wealth that is bad in and of
itself God blesses us with all things
but how do we use that wealth do we
covet it to ourselves or is God using us
as a channel to bless others that's the
question amen amen good answer poverty
doesn't equal piety that's that's good
that's that's good uh Pastor deny my
conclusion to Genesis 2: 6 and 7 and 21-
24 is that both men and women are
created from mud in the image of God
however women were made from the ribs of
their husbands thus they received the
name uh woman because they are the bone
of his bone and flesh of his flesh it
also explains to me why when people are
married they are considered to be one
flesh now my question is knowing that
God's words are yes and amen is it safe
to say that all women are made from the
ribs of their
husbands that's a very good question and
um it seems to be logical but as we
examine the evidence um men do not have
one less rib than women and so while it
seems to be logical it it it really
doesn't explain that in the Bible but
what we see is that God created woman
that way the first one it doesn't mean
that all the others are that way
uh let's take a look uh at the
scriptures you mentioned really quick
Genesis 26 and 7 but a Mist went up from
the earth and watered the whole face of
the ground and the Lord God formed man
of the Dust of the ground and breathed
into his nostrils the breath of life and
Man became a living being jumping to
verse 21 and the Lord caused a deep
sleep to fall on Adam and he slept and
he took one of his ribs and closed up
the Flesh in its place then the rib
which the Lord God had taken from man he
made into a woman and he brought her to
the man and Adam said this is now bone
of my bones and Flesh of My Flesh she
shall be called woman because she was
taken out of man and then then it says
therefore a man shall leave his father
and mother and become and be joined to
his wife and they shall be one flesh and
in becoming one flesh is talking about
that they they now have common interests
common goals and they agree on forming a
family and being a family unit MH uh so
but still the man has his own mind the
woman has her own mind they have to talk
and come to agreements on so many things
as you know uh for example do we want to
have children how many children do we
want to have uh do we want to move to
this city or that City or live where we
are I mean different things and you have
to discuss and agree be as one in your
decisions now if it was as you say
uh that um God has to take a rib out of
man to make a woman then what would God
do for for example for a person well God
knows that uh Robert is going to be
married but his wife is going to pass
away in three years I'm going to have to
take two ribs out of Robert because I'm
going to have to make another wife and
so that doesn't seem to fit and now
there are some people that have been
married uh three times or more because
maybe uh accidents wife passes away and
uh maybe dies of some disease and then
you know does God have to keep taking
ribs out or does he take them and
reserve them but you should be able to
notice say wait a minute I have three
less ribs uh what's going on here so um
while it seems to be logical we have to
come to the conclusion that this was
just a case for the first woman to give
us an understanding that God intends for
men and women to join together and be
one flesh and notice again where um God
took a bone from he didn't take it from
the head uh so that the woman don't
think I'm bigger and than you are you
listen to me or didn't take a bone from
the foot which he could have done and
say I'm just going to take one of these
toes and you're going to have one less
toe the men are going to have one less
toe than the women no uh that way man is
going to say well she's below she's on
my foot I'm just going to step on her
and be over her no it was from the rib
about the middle section of the body of
man indicating they're there to be equal
there to be as equal in in in their
understanding of one another uh one is
not greater than the other however after
after sin entered into the world God did
say that the woman should submit to the
man and please some guys take this too
to too too far and we need to have
balance in this and so let us be careful
with that amen amen well subject of
another question indeed indeed there's a
lot more that can be said about that I
will say that that is the greatest nap
that man ever took when Adam went to
sleep and then he woke up next to the
most beautiful woman on the planet
that's right and it was his wife I mean
that's that's absolutely incredible
greatest nap a man ever took uh pastor
raford
can you please explain Matthew 27: 52
through and
53 yeah these texts are talking about a
resurrection that took place after the
resurrection of Jesus Christ and how a
group of people were resurrected and
went everywhere uh talking about uh
Jesus being a witness for Christ and
then the question you know really um is
well what happened to these people and
are these texts literal or are they you
know um you know just something that is
referring to a future Resurrection it's
going to take place with God's people
but these these texts are actually
literal they they happened at the
resurrection of Jesus uh there are
several supporting verses that we can
look at regarding this actually there's
there's one in the New Testament but
there's a prophecy in the Old Testament
uh in Ephesians
4:8 uh Paul says that when he ascended
on high he LED captivity captive and
gave gifts to men and this is talking
about the people who he led from the
Captivity of the grave and then when he
went to heaven with them he sent the
Holy Spirit to give gifts to his church
so Ephesians 48 is describing what
happened in Matthew 27:52 and 53 at at
his Ascension to the former captives as
well as to the promise of the Holy
Spirit and we see this in the Old
Testament even more specifically Psalm
68:18 I want you to notice what it says
here uh thou Hast ascended on high thou
Hast LED captivity captive thou Hast
received gifts for men yay for the
rebellious also that the Lord God might
dwell among them so Jesus Christ when he
ascended he led captivity captive and he
received gifts specifically the gift of
the Holy Spirit even for the rebellious
in other words the Holy Spirit works
even on the hearts of the rebellious
trying to convict us of sin and lead us
into truth that's what we're told in the
Book of John chapter 16 to convict us of
Truth and of Judgment of righteousness
so the gifts referred to in Psalm 68 are
the same ones that are referred to in
Ephesians chapter 4 they're the gifts of
the holy spirit they're bestowed upon
God's people and when Christ ascended to
heaven after his resurrection he led
this group of people to Heaven who were
resurrected with him after his
resurrection and then he sent the Holy
Spirit to bestow gifts upon his church
now the Bible further supports this
teaching actually in Revelation chapters
4 and 5 if you look there you're going
to find that around the Throne of God in
heaven John sees 4 and 20 seats and upon
the seats he sees these 4 and20 Elders
sitting that are clothed in white
reignment they have crowns on their
heads crowns of gold and uh they're
sitting there in the throne room of God
now if you compare Revelation 4 with
Isaiah chapter 6 and Ezekiel chapter 1
and 2 and and even uh Daniel chapter 7
you're going to find that in all of
those Throne Room scenes in the Old
Testament you never see 24 Elders this
is a new development this is a post
Resurrection picture of the throne that
has included now these 24 Elders now in
the Bible an elder is only ever used to
describe a human being it's never used
to describe an angel or any of the sons
of God from other worlds as John was
mentioning earlier Pastor deny was
mentioning earlier as it's outlined in
Job chapter 1 so who are these Elders
these Elders are actually mentioned 10
times in Revelation chapter 5 chapter 7
chapter 11 chapter 14 chapter 19 but in
Revelation chapter 5 we're given some
key insights into who the elders are
John says and when he had taken the book
talking about Christ the slain lamb
taken the book that no man could take it
was sealed up with Seven Seals the four
beasts and the 24 Elders fell down
before the lamb every one of them have
Harps and golden vials full of odors
which are the prayers of the Saints and
they sing a new song saying you are
worthy to take the book to open the
seals for you were slain and you've
redeemed us to God by your blood out of
every Kindred and tongue and people and
nation and you've made us under our God
Kings and Priests and we shall reign on
the earth that's Revelation 5: 89 and 10
so John has shown that the elders are
redeemed verse 9 by the blood of the
Lamb verse 9 from planet Earth verse 9
this is revelation 5:9 and they are
Kings and Priests of God Revelation 5:10
and they will inherit the earth
Revelation 5:10 so this shows us that
these who were resurrected with Christ
and taken to Heaven from their captivity
to death uh were taken to heaven with
Christ are there in the throne room of
God they human beings redeemed Kings and
Priests who are going to inherit the
earth they an Earnest if you will of the
redeemed of humanity amen amen thank you
for that pastor rafy Pastor deny we'll
come to you uh the Bible says we should
not cry when one dies but cry when one
is born did Jesus really mean that I
shouldn't cry when I lose a loved one I
read of Many Men of God in the Bible
crying for their loved
ones yes that is a good question I'm not
sure where this idea came from that you
should not cry when someone dies uh
there is one verse uh perhaps that
people may look at and say well you're
not supposed to mourn and cry for your
loved one is is when somebody came to
Jesus and said uh um come and follow me
and he says well let me first bury my
mother and father and then Jesus said
let the dead bury the Dead uh but there
is really no place where it says that
you should not cry for your loved ones
let's go ahead and take a look at some
of some scriptures that talk about
mourning and crying one is Ecclesiastes
chapter 3:4 it says there's a time to
weep and a time to laugh a time to mourn
and a time to dance uh Matthew chapter
5:4 blessed are those who mourn for they
shall be comforted uh so there's a
Mourning unfortunately we live live in
this world where we are subject to death
and it's a natural human uh emotion or
feeling uh that we realize we're not
going to be with our loved ones and we
realize this is a painful experience
they have been a part of our lives and
now we are without them uh and so it's a
natural thing and even Jesus himself
more and we're going to take a look at
now at John
11:35 uh this is when Jes Jesus was
taken
to um went to to to see Martha and Mary
because Lazarus had passed away and when
Jesus shows up upon the scene he is
moved to tears there are many people
weeping and uh Jesus identified with
them notice what it says in John 11:35
Jesus wept at the tomb uh it say Jesus
wept at the tomb of his friend Lazarus
you see that Jesus wept it says in the
scriptures in John 11 35 Acts chapter 8
is another place I would like to go to
verse 1 and two now Saul was consenting
to his death that is the death of Steven
at that time a great persecution arose
against the church which was at
Jerusalem and they were all scattered
throughout the region of Judea and
Samaria except the apostles and devout
man carry stevenh to his burial and make
great lamentation for him why because
this great man of God now was not with
them they could not um pray with him and
sing with him and talk about spiritual
things they lamented they mourned they
wept Romans
12:15 the Apostle Paul encouraged
Believers to weep with those who weep
and this is what God does he weeps with
those who weep so if you are um weeping
because of your loved ones passing away
God weeps with you uh in now we move to
Psalms 34:18 it says God is near to
those that are brokenhearted and saves
those who are crushed in spirit and so
God weeps God is identifies with the
suffering uh Psalms
147:3 he heals the Brokenhearted and
binds up their wounds God is very near
to those who are in sorrow because of
their loved ones and he identifies and
so I encourage you uh that if someone
you love passes away
uh go ahead and if that's what uh you
are moved to do go ahead and weep go
ahead and cry this is a a an experience
that is helpful an experience that uh
helps uh the helps somewhat in the
healing process amen uh of uh getting
used to being without your loved ones
now there is a danger of course of uh
and no one can say how long this Haro is
some some some you see some scriptures
where it says that they mour MN for 30
days 40 days um but the idea of mourning
over and over again for months and
months and months that is not healthy
and we encourage you to take the time to
weep but again ask God to help you in
the process to be able to recover and
move about your daily activity you never
forget your loved ones and there may be
times when a sheer may be shed but not
to Great to drive you to Great
Depression amen amen well said well said
keeping all those emotions bottled up
can be harmful and detrimental to one's
health for sure Pastor rafy where does
the bible say the holy spirit is a
person I've been told that this is not
in the Bible can you
explain well that's a great question we
know you know the holy spirit is a
person from the evidence that's given in
the Bible but uh to his personhood but
uh even though the person of the holy
spirit is not explicitly stated in the
text for example
the Holy Spirit has a name the Holy
Spirit has a name Matthew 28: 19 says go
ye therefore and teach All Nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
in the name of the son and in the name
of the Holy Ghost now added that phrase
in the name of for the last two but
that's the inference in the text in the
name of the father and the Son and the
Holy so the Holy Ghost has a name the
Holy Ghost has a pronoun right John 16:
7 and 8 never neveress I tell you the
truth it is expedient for you that I go
away that's Jesus talking if I go not
away the comforter that's talking of the
holy spirit will not come unto you but
if I depart I will send him unto you and
when he is come he will reprove the
world of sin and righteousness and
judgment we talked about that in our
last question about this verse so you
see the Holy Spirit has a pronoun the
Holy Spirit has a will right 1
Corinthians
12:1 but all these works that one and
selfsame spirit dividing to every man
severly as he will the Holy Spirit
divides gifts to his church as he will
so the Holy Spirit has a will the Holy
Spirit has feelings he can be grieved or
as the Greek word translates that word
grieved the Holy Spirit can actually be
made sad that's in Ephesians 4 and
verse3 it says this and grieve not the
holy spirit of God whereby ye are sealed
unto the day of redemption that word
grieve means to distress or make sad so
the Holy Spirit has feelings the Holy
Spirit can be lied to we're told that in
Acts chapter 5 verse three but Peter
dealing with ananas and saf he said to
ananas why has Satan filled thine heart
to lie to the Holy Ghost and keep that
part of the price of the land and the
Holy Spirit can Inspire men to write
second Peter chapter 1: 21 for prophecy
came not in Old Time by the will of man
but holy men of God spake as they were
moved by by the Holy Ghost the holy
spirit is a person that can be spoken
about we read this in John chapter 16
verse 13 how be it when he the spirit of
Truth is come he will guide you into all
truth and he shall not speak of
himself but whatsoever he hears that
shall he speak and he will show you
things to come so the Holy Spirit can be
talked about he's not going to talk
about himself but he can be talked about
so in summary the Holy Spirit has a name
the hly the Holy Spirit has a pronoun
the Holy Spirit has a will the Holy
Spirit has feelings the Holy Spirit can
be lied to the Holy Spirit can Inspire
men to write so the the holy spirit is a
person that can be spoken about yet the
holy spirit is not here in this world to
speak about himself he didn't come to
talk about himself who did he come to
talk about the Bible says the Holy
Spirit came to talk about Jesus now this
last biblical truth may be the reason
why so many people out the personhood of
the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit didn't
come to talk about himself so there's
not a lot communicated in the Bible
about the holy spirit because his point
was that he came to present Jesus not
himself he came to talk about the person
of Jesus Christ his work as declared by
Christ is to be unseen John chapter 3:8
and because the holy spirit is so unseen
we have perhaps made him a
nonperson yet biblically the the holy
spirit is a person having all the
characteristics of a person so the holy
spirit is the ultimate revelation of the
selflessness of God of this character of
self-sacrificing love I hope this is
helpful in answering the question amen
you just listed multiple passages that's
that is excellent great job great job
Pastor densey before we come to you I I
know you might be sitting there saying
well I want to submit some questions I
have some questions now as a result of
watching this program
text your questions to 618 228
3975 again that's 618 228 3975 or email
your questions to Bible QA 3abn.org
Matthew 6:1 177 which talks about
anointing your head when fasting is this
to be
done that is also a very good question
uh now we have to take a look uh at the
context and we have to consider the
times that they were living in and where
they were living in as well and so um
first of all this scripture that you're
talking about I'm just going to read um
in a moment I'm I'm going to read in a
moment this scripture that you're
talking about is dealing with something
that was happening in those days there
were
individuals that when they fasted they
wanted to kind of display that they were
fasting so they were going around with
long faces and sorrow and oh uh brother
Bob there he's fasting uh oh great men
of God uh you know this was the type of
thing that were trying to portray to
people I'm going to pause there for a
moment and say okay should these things
be done there's no harm in not doing
them but what it's really trying to say
there really go about your life as if
everything was normal like you're not
really appearing to fast and so don't be
have a sorrowful face a long phas that
tells people there's something wrong
with you are you okay oh I'm fasting and
so this idea should not be carried by
the way you appear or even the way you
dress let's go ahead and take a look at
the context in Matthew chapter 6 verse
uh 7 beginning verse 16 moreover when
you fast do not be like the Hypocrites
with a sad countenance for they
disfigure their faces that they may
appear to men to be fasting assuredly I
say to you they have their reward but
you when you fast anoint your head and
wash your face so that you do not appear
to men to be fasting but to your father
father who is in the secret place and
your father who sees in secret will
reward you openly MH so this is what
Jesus was saying this is the context of
Matthew 6:17 when you fast anoint your
head and wash your face they did this
every day they anointed their head and
washed their face I'm reading to you
from something that was commenting about
this and I think it's it's a very
appropriate um it says uh do not assume
any new appearance or change your Visage
or your dress the Jews and all the
neighboring nations were much of the
habit of washing and anointing their
bodies this washing was performed at
every
meal they washed and they anointed
themselves and where it could be
affected the head also or other parts of
the body was daily Anointed with sweet
or olive oil in a warm climate exposed
to the great Heat Of The Sun this
practice conducted conduced much to
health preserve the skin smooth and
tender and afford it a most grateful
sensation and odor so this is why they
did it but uh so Jesus is saying uh when
you're fasting again don't be in a
sorrow uh don't be like like the world
is over I'm fasting no appear as normal
if you have to appear in public and let
your light let the let your your face
show that Jesus is living in and so
that's that's the fasting but question
should we fast today uh interestingly
enough Jesus talked about this in
Matthew 9 uh beginning in verse 14 then
the Disciples of John came to him saying
why do you why do we and the Pharisees
fast often but your disciples do not
fast and Jesus said to them can the
friends of the bridegroom mourn mourn as
long as the bridegroom is with them but
the days will come when the bridegroom
will be taken away from them and then
they will fast
and so yes in these times we live in it
would be good to fast there are some
things going on that will require for us
to be close to the Lord and fasting is a
good experience for that amen excellent
answer Pastor rafy if 1,000 human years
is one day to our Lord will that time
frame be the same with us when his elect
go to heaven with him for 1,000 years
I've heard that when the babies are in
heaven their growth will be very slow
not like here on Earth where they grow
pretty fast I think this is a little
backward please help me with this
confusion great question from California
there is no biblical indication that I'm
aware of uh regarding the second part of
your question that babies actually grow
very slowly in heaven now regarding that
first part of your question the Bible
indicates in at least two places that a
day is like a thousand years to the Lord
now one reference is found in 2 Peter 3
verse 8 one that I'm very familiar with
the context of this is is Peter is
explaining why it is it seems that God
has his deay his second coming has been
delayed for so long and so Peter
responds and says but beloved be not
ignorant of this one thing that one day
is with the Lord as a thousand years and
a thousand years as one day so now
another reference to this same point
that I think Peter is really grabbing
this from is found in Psalm 90 ver6 so
it says there in Psalm 990 ver6 for a
thousand years is in thy sight a
thousand years in thy sight is but is as
but a day or is yesterday when it is
passed and as a watch in the night Psalm
90: 6 and the context of this actually
says Psalm 90 vers uh two before the
mountains were brought forth orever thou
has formed the earth and the world even
from Everlasting to Everlasting Thou Art
God so the context of this is talking
about eternity it's talking about uh
Everlasting in as with second Peter
chapter 3 the idea that's being conveyed
here is that in comparison with eternity
or things that are Everlasting or with
infinity a thousand years is like a day
it's like a watch in the night so the
main issue that second Peter is
addressing is why the imper delay of the
second coming of Jesus and the answer is
that we are not to be ignorant of the
fact that in Eternal time A Thousand
Years goes by and it's like a day of
Earthly time right now this is not
suggest suggesting that Eternal time
slows down or speeds up rather it's
suggesting that when we consider that
eternity has no end right then time
takes on a whole new meaning we'll live
for a thousand years and it'll feel like
just a day a night watch so to speak and
again uh it's it's not really a
theological tenant or doctrine that
we're teaching rather it's an
explanations to why Jesus hasn't
returned for 2,000 years that feels like
a long time but from the perspective of
Eternity it's like two days it's like a
very short time and this is the
perspective that God wants us to have to
understand and if we think about it from
this perspective if a thousand years is
like a day in Heavenly time then in
Earthly time when we live for a hundred
years it's like well it's like a tenth
of a day it's like 2.4 hours our our
lives are the James says our in chapter
four our lives are like a vapor they
appear for a little while and they
vanish away a full life of 100 years if
we could live that long let's just say
we're healthy and we follow all of the
the laws of Health that that God has
given us if if we could live for a
hundred years and live a nice life on
this Earth in Heavenly time that would
be like two hours and four 24 minutes
right two hours 24 minutes for 100 years
because eternity stretches out for so
long and that's why God is saying to us
listen don't be ignorant of this Jesus
said he'd be back soon he would return
quickly behold I come quickly in our
estimation he's been gone for 2,000
years but in Heavenly time he's been
gone for two days he's coming back very
soon wow that really puts it into
perspective thank you Pastor rafy very
good uh Pastor densey when will the
Judgment of the living start or has it
already started I believe the pre-advent
Judgment of the Dead began in
1844 will there be an event that will
set a demarcation between the two this
is from Vicky from Florida thank you
Vicki uh that's a very good question and
that is in the mind of many people that
know about the Judgment that has already
begun uh and really I I would like to
set some context for some people that um
are new to this idea the Judgment has
already begun and for that I encourage
everyone to read Daniel chapter 8 and
Daniel chapter 9 and there are many
scriptures that we can go to but that
those give you the context I'm going to
specifically read Daniel 8:14 at this
moment and he said to me for 2, and 300
days then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed so this is talking about the
cleansing of the centuary that is the
centuary in heaven not the centuary on
Earth and uh we understand at seven day
evidence and this is a a study that at
least 45 minutes will help you
understand that the Judgment uh began in
the year
1844 and it begins with God's people
when you remember that the day of
atonement dealt with God's people those
that were Believers in God those were
the ones who benefited from the day of
atonement and so uh the Judgment began
with those that died believing in God
all the way since the beginning uh that
is from Adam and Eve and so the Judgment
of the dead has been taking place
beginning in October of
1844 again uh there's even I think free
literature that we can offer you on that
if you need to more information on that
so we understand that the Judgment of
the Dead began in
1844 however there is no event presented
in the Bible that that helps us
understand that the Judgment of the
living because after finishing with the
judgment of the Dead those that were
Believers in Christ that passed away
then God begins the Judgment of those
that are alive today and that's also a
process when that begins we are not told
it could be that it has already begun
but we don't know it there's nothing
that we can connect this to that will
help us understand it has already begun
but what we are to do is found in
Matthew chapter 24 beginning in verse 42
because we have to understand that we're
we're living in the time of the end and
living in the time of the end Christians
should understand that we should be
living as close to the Lord as possible
because the devil is rumbling around
seeking whom he may devour Matthew 24
beginning in verse 42 watch therefore
for you do not know what hour your lord
is coming uh and we don't know the hour
when the Judgment of the living began
either but know this that if the Master
of the House had known what hour the
thief would come
he would have watched and not allowed
his house to be broken into therefore
you also be ready for the son of man is
coming at an hour you do not expect what
we need to be doing today is be in this
watchful being in in uh I'm going to
call it holy communion close communion
with the Lord that whenever the Lord
comes we will be ready amen amen thank
you Pastor deny thank you Pastor refy I
know we have a little bit more to come
we are going to take a short break we
want to share with you how you can
submit your questions um if you haven't
done so so that they can be answered in
future programs and as always we want to
encourage you to study God's word don't
go anywhere we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
will'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org Q&A for answers from God's
word where has the time gone I don't
know but I hope that you've been
enjoying this program at this point in
time Pastor rafy I just want to open up
the floor for any final thoughts that
you may have well I was really blessed
by a couple of the questions that Pastor
densey answered one of them about
fasting that was really interesting that
when they ate they would anoint
themselves and clean and it sounds to me
like when you don't eat you don't anoint
yourself and Jesus was saying to people
hey if you're fasting uh go ahead and
anoint your oil as though you're not
fasting right anoint yourself as though
you're not fasting with that oil in
other words don't tell people you're
fasting which is what Pastor densey was
saying but the connection with anointing
your head with oil was really intriguing
to me also I was thinking about another
question about Sorrowing for the dead
and I think we get that idea from 1
Thessalonians chapter 4 where it says
that we shouldn't sorrow as others do
and perhaps we concluded from that that
we shouldn't sorrow at all but I I think
Pastor deny did a great job answering
that no we need we need to connect with
people and weep with those that Weep the
Bible's very clear on that but we don't
have to sorrow as others who have no
hope we have a hope in Jesus Christ for
that Resurrection praise God amen amen
thank you Pastor densey what about you I
I just want to say you know that we are
blessed to have the opportunity to have
the Holy scriptures and uh God wants to
teach us God wants us to dedicate take
time to study the scriptures because he
he's longing for people to know his
message and to be able to share with
others and so I I'm going to just read
here really quick 2 Timothy 3:15 and
that from the a childhood you have known
the holy scriptures which are able to
make you wise for salvation through
faith which is in Christ Jesus we need
to do that today amen amen thank you
both for coming on and answering these
these questions thank you for submitting
your questions make sure you study God's
word and apply the principles to your
life until next time God bless you
[Music]